I swear I'm a better boyfriend
than I am a gingerbread maker, for sure.
I hope I am.
(upbeat holiday music)
Welcome to Cookie Kitchen.
Today we're gonna be
decorating gingerbread men
in our ideal man form.
I think I'm gonna do a spin on it,
so it's not gonna be my ideal
man, but it's more gonna be
what happens to a man in New York City.
I'm gonna go with a
post-impressionism approach.
You know what you're gonna do?
No, but I think I'm just
gonna use my iPhone,
and just Google some photos.
Okay, I was gonna be
creative, but it's fine.
Can we just start?
- [Ian] Cool.
- [Alec] Yes, okay.
I'm gonna start with the hair.
It's important.
I'm gonna do an unconventional approach.
That Friday night approach?
Oh?
This is gonna be interesting 'cause
I've not done this in ever.
Probably forever.
This is actually my first time,
we'll se how this turns out.
I'm just gonna give you
your basic Smiley Go-lucky.
Kind of like how an ideal man
should be, smiley and go-lucky
- [Man] That's some swoosh right there.
Yeah, you need to calm down.
'Cause it's gonna be awesome,
and just keep eating your cookie.
Okay, I think I'm gonna make mine
like an 80's exercise guy.
Really into exercising and
working out and getting sweaty.
Why not?
I'm still chewing on this, by the way.
Maybe I'm gonna give mine a
garland-like scarf situation.
And I could probably cut
some off and then put some
on the neck.
Look at me being artsy, crafty!
I love it.
I get really competitive when
it comes to crafty things.
Oh, it's on.
I'm not sure is this is
an 80's work out gingerman
anymore, it's more like Serena Williams,
but who wouldn't want a bite of that?
We always end up--
We always end up competing
Every time.
I win.
Let's see what happens here.
Uhh, I shouldn't have done
that, I'm not good at this.
That's sweet.
Oh. (bleep)
Are you tasting everything?
Oh yeah. (laughs)
I'm doing more of that
than I am decorating.
I like the classic approach though.
That's how I like my guy.
Classic with a little
bit of a edge to him.
Hence the missing half of his face.
You can't eat that though.
I don't care, it's more about the look.
You guys, I'm really
nailing this, for someone
who's never done this
before, look how cute.
I love yours.
Told you I'd win.
When I eat my gingerbread man,
I'm gonna want him to taste
good, so the more sugar
the better.
Are we doing the big reveal?
I think the big reveal.
Do we need a drum roll?
(bangs table)
(drum roll)
Alright.
Go.
Oh, I'm not done.
Oh my God.
One, two, three.
This one's mine.
My Richard Simmons
inspired gingerbread man.
I think they look cute.
Cute.
I'm kind of impressed with us.
What happens to you after you
enter the New York City dating pool.
You literally get eaten alive.
And I did Kylie Minogue.
I definitely think I
went completely tangent,
not what I want my ideal man to be.
I don't know about you,
but I think was really therapeutic for me.
Yeah, I clearly won.
Mine isn't necessarily my
ideal man, but definitely fit.
Look at those sweatbands.
I'd kinda still wear those today.
I love the movement.
'Cause you really see
the emotional journey.
- [Man] Oh I like yours now.
I like the hair. (laughs)
I know. See good ideas, right?
See he was hatin' on my
side swoop, but it's good.
I wouldn't call that a side swoop,
I'd call that a cinnamon roll swirl.
Maybe that'll be my drag name.
For popping that gingerbread
man cherry, I guess,
I feel like it was a success.
Yeah.
I think they make a really good couple.
And mine still didn't mess up, so boom.
I'm glad that I could be here
for your first gingerbread experience.
Mine's a little destroyed now,
but it's all about the fun
and the character.
Mhmm.
And I'd say there's a lot of both.
And that's how the cookie crumbles.
That's how his cookie
crumbles, mine doesn't.
Bye.
(laughs)